j'ai été au pire rendez-vous de ma vie
j'étais chez le dentiste
déjà hier déjà ça m'a ça m'a qu'un
weekend depuis vendredi soir je ne pense
au rendez-vous chez le dentiste à 11h
aujourd'hui frère je suis resté deux
heures là-bas aïe il a voulu il avait
enlevé une dent et il a été chercher une
dent d'un gars qui m'a amené à la place
et le dentiste comme il sait qu'il va
défoncer mon frère il dit ce que je peux
te mettre un petit peu de musique
et là tu te retrouves avec Philippe
[Rires]
traversière c'est parti et là tu attends
et là le gars veux te parler tu as
marqué les dentistes maintenant à son
frère tu sais pas il sait pas que tu
peux pas lui répondre le gars là je vais
te mettre du XR2 sur la dose de façon
vraiment à solidifier la couronne et
ensuite je vais passer par la prémolaire
tu vas voir tout va bien se passer ça te
va bien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il a tapé sur le marteau et ça te fait
ça et ici tu as des vibrations
j'ai passé pire moment de ma vie
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
tu veux que j'appelle le dentiste ouais
c'est ce qu'il a dit non il a dit j'ai
jamais vu un gars comme ça
[Applaudissements]
les chéris s'il vous plaît anesthésie
bien sûr mais bon mais alors même avec
anesthésie
je l'appelle j'appelle non mais tu sais
ce que j'ai vécu c'est pas ce que j'ai
vécu toi bah c'est pas mykono son Rambo
mais du coup il va falloir que vous y
retourner pour changer la dent pour
mettre une dent euh
définitive
mais il est il est beau gosse c'est vrai
Christophe il s'appelle et vous avez pas
mal là la douleur se réveille pas y a
que toi qui pense à moi
je cherche le numéro là
tu peux m'envoyer le numéro du dentiste
vrai
il y a pas de
dentiste c'est pas moi qui prend
rendez-vous chez le dentiste
parce que Monsieur
[Applaudissements]
j'ai l'impression qu'elle est il est
incroyable il a fait comme ça la dent il
a moulé sur mon corps ouais ouais comme
ça
comme dans Ghost quand ils font la
poterie comme ça
[Rires]
est-ce que vous avez l'antécédent de la
personne qui avait la dent avant vous
votre dent à vous elle est où l'ancienne
elle est partie là elle est pas allé en
Turquie là c'est comme une mèche de
Bieber ça ça se vend une fortune bien
sûr récupère les dents en fait ils vous
font croire que c'est des dents qui ont
été fabriqués mais en fait c'est les
dents des autres personnes là votre dent
elle est déjà chez quelqu'un
donc il a les dents de ses ex
emples
bon il va m'appeler quand alors lundi
prochain
là il va me mettre une nouvelle dans la
comme ça une dent de zèbre
[Rires]
[Musique]
il avait trois dents frère
non mais il y a les trois dents de ouf
là il a une là frère
non je vais peut-être y aller là bon
dentiste sur la tête de ma mère en tissu
oui c'est magnifique tu le vois plus tu
vois que c'est donc piano frère
moi parce que il faut faire attention
avec les dents aussi il y a des gars de
télé-réalité tout ça il faut faire les
dents on dirait qu'ils ont du kiri sur
les dents
tu as toujours envie de l'an dernier
j'ai eu l'occasion de voir des pieds ils
sont magnifiques
c'est tout naturel mais dans son témoin